welcome to this video playing somewhere
Jardine Wow never played this guy s mujh
are you even as a here I've look Elmo
jadi @ gmail.com with a picture it's got
to 640 here and 1800 in blitz and
nothing at all here this is very
suspicious ok let's see what's happening
yep indonesia ok let's see what what
happens I really don't think I'm playing
too many cheetahs on the ICC but
recently I played one guy even two times
who cheated quite obviously and let's
see what what this is it could be just a
good player Union didn't know that the
circumstances are slightly suspicious ok
I played this trick eh6 line the line
sometimes named after the Russian GM
Vladimir bull marking his some pioneered
this line
yeah now with h4 I just saved the whole
temple over the normal theoretical line
okay 25 may be interesting attacking
here maybe I get to place your form
would be very nice okay mm-hmm play keep
it simple meaning just taking here let's
just take a look takes Bishop takes mm
don't know if this is this completely
equal it's almost a theoretical position
I think
yeah hoopty seven was check problem
check
yeah this is completely okay the
position is so just just equal it's very
nice for me that he has played H for
this gives me some counter play with
rook g8 and yeah i wonder if i should
play Knight e5 even here or or just take
it's maybe plane I'd be five if I don't
take
yeah okay this guy is simply a computer
cheetah you don't spend five seconds to
retake and with all this with all this
other stuff the strange rating and so on
okay well let's see what happens the
position is of course completely okay
for me but um let's see
check
check
yeah h5 you don't want unknown a rock t5
is not good probably because he's got
this two against one f5 and I could play
a five if I have him simplifying yeah I
feared this I've yet this but i thought
i'm quick enough i thought i'm cooking
enough maybe i'm not a for a g4 f
h6 g4 and I'm going over to the edge
from
okay King c70 is playing age six yeah
welcome welcome to the world of Houdini
age six I mean it's really cute right
but it's just computed cheating I came
black where's I yeah okay well I did get
bent pretty quickly so i'm pretty pretty
obvious okay well what can you do um
yeah i'll still post this game despite
the being despite the obvious cheating
but simply because of this this funny
funny thing here at the end let's let's
reflect this with with my engine how
black should defend king be 60 still
seems to defend I I [ __ ] I only now saw
this idea it was too late I thought that
this would would be enough but Jack King
King b6 seems to seems to hold King b6
and rocked he said this is what because
I this wire by one this is why I didn't
want to do that Wow difficult Roxy for
now Andrew cage for her so still sleep
this still seems to hold
yeah this is more precise for some
reason and then approach here yeah maybe
you can still draw but it's difficult
against Houdini of course alright thanks
for watching